hello welcome to break through from
science mission I am sadashiva pi and
going to discuss couple of breakthrough
papers published in the week of May 5th
first we are going to discuss a paper
published by Dennis from dr. Ramez Berks
lab in nature the paper talks about the
use of unnatural amino acids for the
replication of DNA in e.coli and growth
of the cells with the new DNA unnatural
base paths used in the study are
structurally compared with the deoxy
cytosine and deoxy groaning as shown in
this figure the authors tested the
stability and uptake from the culture
media containing growing ecoli
overexpressed with a nucleotide
triphosphate transporters which is the
author's previously shown to work better
in transporting triphosphates into the
cells after optimizing sa conditions
author show that unnatural phosphates
especially triphosphates are stable in
the media and are taken up by the cells
although authors observed both extra and
intracellular dephosphorylation the
ratio of triphosphate to
dephosphorylation products inside the
cell remained roughly constant
indicating the extracellular
concentrations and transporter mediated
influx are sufficient to compensate for
intracellular decomposition also the
intracellular concentrations of intact
triphosphates are significantly above
the sub micromolar values of the
unnatural triphosphates required by
polymerase s for replication next
authors looked at if unnatural base
pairs are incorporated during the
replication to determine whether ecoli
can use the imported unnatural
triphosphate to stably propagate ecoli
cells they were first transformed with
the plasmid encoding
transporter and grown in media
containing unnatural triphosphates and
one millimolar iptg to induce
transporter production cells were then
transformed with the plasmid called I
enf in which dadt pair at position 505
replaced with unnatural amino acids cell
growth was monitored by our culture
turbidity as shown in this figure growth
was significantly slower in the presence
of iptg but addition of unusual base
pairs resulted in only a slight further
decrease in growth initially and the lag
was eliminated at the later stage about
18 hours of cell growth to determine the
level of unnatural base pair retention
plasmid was recovered digested and
dephosphorylated to single nucleosides
and analyzed by lc-ms a clear signal of
unnatural amino acid was observed in the
mass spectra to independently confirm
and quantify the retention of unnatural
base pair in the recovered plasmid the
relevant region was amplified by pcr in
the presence of unnatural amino acid
triphosphate and biotin elated analog as
shown in this figure analysis by
streptavidin gel shift showed that
sixty-seven percent of the amplified DNA
contained biotin no shift was observed
in control experiments when the
amplification product obtained with
unnatural amino acid was analyzed by
Sanger sequencing in the presence of
unnatural triphosphates the sequencing
chromatogram showed a complete
termination at the position of unnatural
base pair incorporation in contrast
application products obtained from
controls propagated under identical
conditions showed no termination these
experiments confirm the incorporation of
unnatural base pair in the plasmid
during replication authors looked at
unnatural base pair stability inside the
cells since unnatural base pair was
retained over 15 hour period of growth
indicating that it is not efficiently
excised by DNA repair pathways to test
further these hypotheses and to examine
the retention during prolonged
stationary phase growth authors repeated
experiments but monitored unnatural base
pair retention cell growth and unnatural
triphosphate decomposition for up to six
days without providing any additional
unnatural fast triphosphates as shown in
this figure at 15 and 19 hour of growth
the cultures reached an optical density
at 600 nanometer of approximately 0
point 9 and 1 point 2 respectively and
both unnatural triphosphates decomposed
to seventeen to twenty percent and ten
to sixteen percent of their initial
concentration retention of unnatural
base pair after fifteen hour was
ninety-seven percent and ninety-five
percent as determined by gel shift and
sequencing respectively and after 19
hour it was 91% and ninety-five percent
as the culture center stationary phase
and the triphosphate decomposed
completely plasmid loss began to compete
with replication but even then retention
of unnatural base pair remained at
approximately 45 and fifteen percent at
days three and six respectively moreover
when unnatural amino acid was lost it
was replaced by dadt the shape of the
retention versus curve mirrors that of
growth versus time curve taken together
these data suggest in the absence of
unnatural triphosphate the unnatural
base pair is eventually lost by
replication mediated miss pairing and
not from the activity of DNA
repair pathways so the authors were able
to grow the cells with unnatural base
pass for the first time and it is a big
breakthrough in the field now let's look
at another paper published by nawazish
and mink from dr. Hussain slab contrary
to the earlier notion this paper
demonstrates that cardiomyocytes retain
proliferating capability at early
neonatal stage let's see what is known
about cardiomyocyte differentiation
cardiomyocytes terminally differentiated
by postnatal day 5 in mouse extensive by
nucleation of cardiomyocytes happen
between p5 2 p-10 considered terminal
differentiation marker by p7 heart slows
regenerative capability during early
period allison's that is p phi 2 p 14
the expression of genes responsible for
cell cycle entry mitosis and cytokinesis
falls precipitously between p10 and p21
that is the weaning period estimates of
s-phase indicate that cardiomyocytes are
quiescent cardiomyocytes added to post
neonatal hearts at a rate of point seven
six percent per year only point two
percent of mononuclear cardiomyocytes
retain plurality of capacity this
indicates that there wasn't much growth
of cardiomyocytes in the early stages
author see related total cardiomyocyte
number that is cpn in ventricular
myocardium by enzymatic this aggregation
and direct cell counting estimates of
total cardiomyocyte numbers identify two
distinct increases in cpn a forty
percent increases between p1 and p4 and
a further party for transient further
forty percent increase between
b14 and pa gane a total of twenty-two
percent of post p14 cpn increase
occurred by 4pm on p 15 that is p 15a
with no further change between p 18 and
p3 25 to determine the time of onset of
mitosis authors measure the expression
of several mitosis promoting genes in
cardiac when trickles daily from p13 to
p16 what is defined they found five to
12 fold increases in mrna levels of all
these genes on the morning of p15 with
the levels on p15 falling to near p 13
levels thus cardiomyocytes are M phase
as early as 9am on p15 authors found
extensive proliferation in P at a recent
heart transfer section of ventricle of
my sacrificed between 8am and 12pm
revealed a 36 fold increase in left went
to Cal cardiomyocyte mitosis between P
14 and p 15 followed by an abrupt 5.84
decrease between P 15 and p16 this
changes paralleled changes in expression
of mitosis promoting genes as shown
previously nuclear localization in
aurora be in most of the mitotic
cardiomyocytes indicated that these
cells were in prophase mitotic
cardiomyocyte nuclear we're not
uniformly distributed throughout left
ventricular wall being two point fold
more abundant in sub endocardial than
sub epicardial myofibers of the p 15
left ventricle approximately ten percent
of the total mitotic p15 cardiomyocytes
were mononuclear and ninety percent were
by nuclear authors calculated
the number of mono by and multinuclear
cardiomyocytes added to the ventricles
between morning of p15 and afternoon of
p15 by multiplying average cpn by the
percentages of cardiomyocytes that were
mononuclear by nuclear or multinucleate
at these times the most striking change
was 1.93 folding place in 10 nuclear
cardiomyocytes by nuclear cells went
down by fifteen percent and multinuclear
cells went up by 1.5 fold there was
decrease in volume size of the mono by
nuclear cells by forty-five percent and
sixty percent respectively authors
determined that this increase in bursts
of cells is primarily by splitting of
mononuclear cells and by nuclear cells
as demonstrated in this schematic
wherein by nuclear cells without
undergoing cytokinesis become
multinuclear cells and with cytokinesis
give rise to mononuclear and by nuclear
cells but cell volume goes down
similarly mononuclear cells split and
become smaller mononuclear cells and
also some by nuclear cells which are
small in size immediately after p10 the
rate of heart growth exceeded that of
body growth resulting in a rapid fifty
percent increase in heart to body weight
ratio between p10 and p50 p17
in addition ventricular alpha beta MHC
mRNA ratio also increased fivefold and
alpha MHC levels increased 2.54 while
atrial natriuretic factor mrna levels a
marker for pathological hypertrophy was
not significantly increased this
molecular and morphological signature
suggests a thyroid hormone mediated
effect since neither physiological nor
pathological cardiac hypertrophy causes
large increases in the alpha beta mhz
mRNA ratio consistent with this
hypothesis serum t three levels
increased 5.64 between p10 and p2 are to
determine if t3 is necessary for the
post pete and cardiac growth was
inhibited t3 biosynthesis by
propylthiouracil that is PTU PTU
administration from p7 decreased serum t
three levels at p14 by forty three
percent prevented the increase in alpha
beta MHC mRNA ratio and reduced heart
wait more than body weight so that p14
to be 18 the heart to body weight ratio
of PT you treated mice were not
significantly different from Pete and
mice this is consistent with the high
levels of circulating t3 regulating
cardiac growth during the early
adolescence the subsequent decrease in
heart to body ratio between p16 and p21
was due to reduced rate of heart growth
during which body weight continue to
rise but not due to reduction in serum
t3 which remained high between p12 and
puberty these findings
suggest between p10 and p14 t3 is
critically modulates the mod of x which
body weight to circulatory volume drives
heart growth allowing a more rapid
increase in heart sighs during early
pre-adolescence KKT pathway in heart is
both survival and proliferating IDF one
is mainly secreted by cardiac fibroblast
akt is required for physiological growth
in response to I gf1 stimulation t3
regulates igf-1 mrna in osteoblasts by
IDF one ty roid hormone responsive
element igf-1 causes fetal heart
cardiomyocyte proliferation by
activating igf-1 receptor p 13 k a k t
pathway authors found that I df1 mrna
and idea of one expression are increased
2.3 fold and 39 fold respectively in p15
related to p10 hearts activation of
igf-1 receptor requires phosphorylation
that activates phosphoinositide a KT PT
you suppress the ratios both the ratios
indicating the involvement of t3
inactivating IJ of one akt pathway in
p15 ventricles in cardiomyocytes nuclear
localization of akt is functionally
important for the proliferation akt was
mostly localized in cardiomyocyte nuclei
in p15 hearts while in p13 arts its
localization was cytoplasmic this
finding supports a role 43 in triggering
p15 cardiomyocyte hyperplastic burst
previously extensive cardiac
regeneration after injury leading to
restoration of the ventricular wall
without scar formation is observed in p1
but not P 7rp 14 mice authors postulated
that cardiomyocyte proliferation at p15
might hello cardiac regeneration they
evaluated the hypothesis by subjecting
my stew cardio my myocardial infraction
and comparing these response to those of
p2 and p21 animals does there was
virtual absence of scar tissue in p12
myocardial infraction mice at p7 and 21
days post-infection that is dpi compared
to mice at p15 as shown in this figure
authors then compared in fact sizes no
significant differences in interrupt
sizes @ p @ 1 dpi p21 in fact sizes were
6.8 for greater at seven dpi then p to
inflict sizes while in fact size was
intermediate in p15 hearts brdu and
alpha i MHC myocardial in remote
nonischemic border zones of p2p 15 and
p21 hearts at seven dpi showed fewer
self with the evidence of DNA synthesis
in p15 hearts compared to p2 hearts and
the absence of such cells in p21 hearts
thus in mirin hearts the capacity of
cardiac regeneration after p15 is
intermediate between that at p12 and at
p21 taken together this publication
provides compelling evidence for the
retention of cardiomyocyte proliferate
to you
Pitons long after neonatal period which
requires a significant revision of
generally accepted view that
cardiomyocytes terminally
differentiation thank you for watching
breakthroughs in from science mission